dams in pakistan's north are full
the floodgates are open
more water is headed downstream
to lowlands where rainfall has already
submerged everything in sight it is
difficult to imagine where more water
will go
army helicopters are dropping aid to
stranded communities
small mercies from the air
that pale in comparison to the calamity
across the country and beyond
boat rescues are happening around the
clock to evacuate people stranded by
standing water
where there are no boats people are
walking out
wading through the water carrying
whatever they can
self-rescue and sin
is not for the faint of heart
we have nothing help me help me now
we'll all die
look at this there is nothing left to
save and no one is coming to us at night
there are bandits running around here
hunger is making us crazy what can we do
fed up of sitting on the side of the
road for more than two weeks no help in
sight the residents of one village have
taken matters into their own hands
what people here are telling us is that
this is dakoi country they're worried
about thieves and what they're trying to
do now is protect the few remaining
possessions they were able to salvage
from their flooded homes
in the absence of anything else people
here are helping each other get to
safety
that's it we're living now we can do
manual labor to save our children or
else they will die what can we do we're
poor our animals will die our kids will
die then we will die
deep in the heart of sindh province in
villages whose names won't show up on
any maps
no helicopters are coming over the
horizon
no boat motors can be heard in the
distance signaling salvation
people here are tired of waiting for a
savior they are packing up and on the
move
zayn basravi al-jazeera shakarpur
district sen pakistan